[Musique]
jean michel fourgous bonjour et
bienvenue au web to you à
montigny-le-bretonneux je vous en prie
pour votre café politique vous êtes le
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines également maire
d'elancourt pour débuter cette émission
avant de parler de votre parcours comme
c'est la tradition pour le café
politique j'aimerais qu'on parle de
votre famille politique justement les
républicains qui ont un nouveau chef de
file nouveau chef de file c'est laurent
wauquiez est-ce que c'est l'homme de la
situation
ou est ce que vous faites partie des
sceptiques on va dire qu il faut lui
laisser sa chance comme on dit souvent
ça pour
l'indicé pour monsieur macron si je
crois sans gros monsieur hollande
bon là comme en 2010 où l'amour voilà
monsieur wauquiez ce que je connais de
lui c'est que bon c'est un garçon on sur
le plan intellectuel quittait ses
brillants il a été majeur de normale sup
dans son avis règles histoire je prends
et major de l'ena ou c'est assez rare en
place et d'autres performances
intellectuelles
c'est
quelqu'un qui a déjà une expérience qui
est très terrain pour un entre
guillemets un profil un peu comme cela
bon beaucoup appris ici le vent les
thèmes politiques de droite très terrain
et sur ses orientations sur les choix
qu'il adore et qu'il a pu exprimer
je suis certain son parti xavier
bertrand est parti par exemple c'est en
robe ont écouté on sait que xavier
bertrand
d'autres
aussi on en
envisages certainement un jour ont le
potentiel d'abord de postuler un jour ou
l'autre responsabilités on s'est compris
le voilà alors tous les gens qui sont
susceptibles d'être candidats mais s'en
vont pas applaudir je suppose la
victoire de monsieur qui a priori peu
sucre événement même fonction donc voilà
il ya un minimum de rivalité qui
explique plus ce genre de commentaire
quand j'entends ce que j'entends sur
monsieur qu'est d'extrême droite enfin
du front national enfin faut foncer
explosé de rire cette histoire je le
connais il a été député avec moi il
vient de la droite sociale monsieur qui
est bon vous êtes mais en 53 vous avez
effectué de nombreux mandats locaux et
nationaux on va et venir mais le premier
engagement en politique pour vous monte
à caen
quel moment vous êtes avis il faut que
je m'engage à écouter j'étais chercheur
et j'ai créé une entreprise et quand
j'ai créé une entreprise
donc si j'ai fait un doctorat sur le
numérique j'ai fait un des poumons peut
être des premières thèses sur l'impact
du numérique précisé après j'ai créé une
société à une start up sur numérique est
au bout de trois ans je vais utiliser le
fameux crédit impôt recherche les bus ou
trois ans j'ai l'administration fiscale
qui vient qui contrôle les boîtes qui
les startups en numérique dauchot ces
partis qui nous ont assassiné il nous
avons repris alors qu'on ait pas
beaucoup de moyens ils ont mis nos
entreprises à genoux et là et là je me
suis amusé contre contre cette
administration contre l'état une équipe
ils vont ils enlevaient le crédit impôt
recherche parce qu'il disait que le
numérique n'était ne devait pas être un
sujet de recherche
on sait que le numérique est le premier
des multiplicateurs d'innovation dans le
monde aujourd'hui enfin à l'époque
c'était il ya plus de trente ans il
s'est pas compris celles et il mettait à
genoux les start-ups du zèbre et là j'ai
décidé de me d'aller expliquer à l'état
entre guillemets et je me suis rendu
compte des petits uniquement pour ça
pour aller également sur le financement
des petites entreprises que moi je vais
tellement souffert d'une part en levant
de cognin prochain d'autre part avec les
difficultés pour trouver des supports ou
dans les banques dans les business
angels que je me suis planté pour ça
pour changer ses règles pour aider pour
qu'on attrape pas les petits chefs
d'entreprise qui en plus tu es sur des
sujets innovants avec avec beaucoup de
potentiel mais était gelée changé
puisque dès que j'ai été élu williams
avait modifié le crédit impôt recherche
aujourd'hui on l'a passée de 400
millions des aides aux petites
entreprises comme nous à 4 nuls et plus
de 4 milliards dont vous voyez j'ai et
si on avait appliqué la loi que j'ai
fait en fait avec mais mme pécresse on
l'avait appliquée si je l'avais au
moment même où se seraient pas connues
en tout cas vous êtes élu député pour la
première fois c'était en 1993 en 2002
puis en 2007 2012 vous êtes battu par
hamon vous jurer de prendre votre
revanche lors du prochain scrutin sauf
qu'ils aient une nouvelle vague et c'est
la vague en marche
vous avez été dans quel état d'esprit à
ce moment là non mais j'ai pas joué
prudemment je me suis mais je comprends
pas que la classe politique de l'ère des
gens
comme monsieur hamon qui qui raconte à
des jeunes un peu dépourvu d'expérience
économique le redis je vais jouer de
donner 1000 euros
par mois à vie sans travailler pour
obtenir il ya un problème
la france doit se pencher que ce soit
monsieur monde aux meilleurs mais on
peut pas continuer comme ça gère que bon
soit vous avez une expérience des
résultats et vous présenter pour
améliorer le sort des français soit si
c'est que du baratin que de la
manipulation que du cynisme non il faut
il faut plus française sans par les
députés doivent s'emparer de ce sujet on
peut pas continuer à faire faire des
lois par des gens qui n'ont aucune
expérience devant managériale sérieuse
aucun résultat sérieux souvent voilà ça
peut pas durer quand je ne suis pas pour
moi je suis pas inquiet dans la vie mais
c'est pau s'est passé pour la france il
ya un problème il ya les autres et ainsi
de démocratie tue mais se parlent et
benoît hamon il ya une autre vague et
revient sur la vague en marchant bien
sûr mais sur ma question vous étiez déçu
à ce moment là vous vous ai dit bon là
la politique ça va devenir compliqué
d'obtenir un nouveau mandat
non mais oh super bon petit clocher de
l'économie je suis plus
un économiste entre guillemets
pragmatique qu'un politique mais je ne
comprends pas effectivement je n'ai pas
très bien compris la candidature de
monsieur hamon puis il continue à voir
les jeunes surtout bien sûr tous les
gens un peu d'une érable ça c'est celle
ci bon et puis il ya un humain des mais
aussi vont alors mettre à jour du départ
clairement ce qui a résulté de la 11ème
à elle veut être député la peur du débat
et au premier tour avec les autres
candidats et au second tour vous l'avez
rencontré parce que vous êtes maire
d'elancourt lé député de la 11e
circonscription c'est votre
circonscription
écoutez j'ai la plus grosse commune
elle n'est pas venue me voir mais
c'était quand même plusieurs mois
qu'elle est élue mais bon côté là ça
fait partie du jeu c'est ce que c'est ça
le jeu démocratique mais en plus j'ai
d'autre que d'autres de mes collègues
qui ont des types d'expériences qui ont
été battus qu'ils avaient des résultats
par des gens de totalement inconnu sans
élection attention si vous affaiblissez
l'assemblée nationale si vous mettez des
gens qui n'ont pas d'existence propre
certains n'ont pas de résultats à eux
qui n'ont pas de propositions fondées
sur l'expérience sur les résultats
laisser le pays une assemblée qui du
coup n'est plus un contre-pouvoir une
assemblée nationale du pays doit être le
contre-pouvoir de l'exécutif c'est ça
l'équilibré
c'est fondamental sinon c'est les techno
qui dirige ce quelqu'un aujourd'hui
regardez la ligne 18 ils ont fait passer
ça les députés il était là pas un mot il
a fallu qu'on est allé chercher dira m
et c'est votre boulot les gars ah bon
c'est d'être bonne
dallier d'aller expliquer que dans notre
circonscription les effets d'une loi
proposé par des techno les arbitrages
faits par des techno sadc un impact sur
notre circonscription sur nos
administrés et il a fallu qu'on leur
explique mais bon c'est vrai alors pas
toucher une allocation quand même
meilleure que d'autres un jeu jouent pas
ils sont pas tous mais beaucoup de gens
fin que l'inexpérience n'est pas une
vertu enfin il pour être député
mais bon gré moi je vous sais je
m'adapte jeu c'est de comprendre les les
variables de mon pays mais je suis
inquiet parce que vous avez 100% d'être
du pib' ceram vous avez près de 100
milliards de déficit c'est pas 70 cibles
proches de 100 milliards quand vous
faites la somme de tous et puis vous
avez le plafond des impôts quitte au
maximum
moi tous les records mondiaux
aujourd'hui il ya six millions et demi
de de chômeurs toutes catégories
il nous faut plus que jamais des gens
d'expérience je postule pas c'est bien
ça me va très bien je suis très heureux
que vous parlez c'est concret beaucoup
des nationales là encore dans votre
discours vous parler vraiment de la
situation au niveau national des
déficits du chômage
vous n'avez plus d'ambition nationale
maintenant que vous êtes président de
l'agglomération 39 je pense que homo ce
qui me passionne c'est d'aider des
jeunes à avoir envie d'entreprendre
ensuite de les aider à formaliser un
projet
comme on dit souvent c'est un prototype
mais c'est pour ça qu'on a fait là qu
batteur ils peuvent définir leur projet
avec des des conseillers de très haute
qualité
puis après les aider à réussir de
trouver de l'argent de c'est dur de
trouver de l'argent je veux que j'ai
vécu c'est pour ça que moi j'aurais
adoré un incubateur et j'aurais
certainement encore mieux réussi ici si
j'avais eu un incubateur comme ça parce
que je fais des bêtises que je ne sais
pas ils font pas les mêmes bêtises enfin
j'essaie de faire quelque chose et puis
après les aider à trouver des clients
vous avez vu le l'allèle le business le
skate business day où on le retrouve 10
prospects quasiment 5 à 10 prospère en
une journée
lassé des choses comme ça les aider à
trouver les bons partenaires les bons
clients et bon réseau les soutiens
financiers et pas à leur faire faire des
qui comprennent les lois aussi le crédit
impôt recherche les aide à comprendre le
grille impôt recherche qu'on puisse se
passer si limoux le monsieur est celle
ci donc voila moi c'est passionnant
d'aidé
quand vous quand vous êtes un petit peu
et enfin un petit peu âgé je peux
sûrement mais mais le plaisir vous le
trouvez à aider les autres c'est pas moi
je me bats pas pour ma réussite c'est
bon je sais pas je ne peux pas t'en pas
je ne tiens pas d'être ministre sur
monsieur chirac m'avait promis je vais
refuser que ça semble très compliqué
d'ombré il faut les aviez refusé
c'est le budget de la politique de l'été
le ministre la politique de la ville à
l'époque et parce que j'étais à
montreuil parce que j'étais député de
trappes en cours et j'ai dr synology
bassin qui pensaient que j'étais traité
pourrait être mise à pied alors que bon
il m'aurait donné l'innovation et
la recherche je peux les entreprises oui
mais pas non mais je lui ai dit voilà
mais il comprenait pas il pensait que
tout jeune député devait être ambitieux
et une rêvé d'être ministre la bombe
mais je te planter votre livre de chevet
ou es ce que vous avez le temps de lire
encore j'ai lu tout beaucoup de sites ou
de blaye où j'ai fait dix neuf rapports
scientifiques quand j'étais cnrsc league
et sur scène j'ai écrit dit bouquin
public et puis j'ai fait 10 me diddy
rapport parlementaire ac j'ai beaucoup
lu aujourd'hui d'abord je lis beaucoup
bien sûr sur tablette
mais bon là donc c'est différent je lis
bricout de condenser d'articles faut
dire qu'on vous en vous en envoie un
paquet parce que tous les interlocuteurs
et disent tiens il faut que jean louis
saha fourgous match et c'est bon vous
avez un nombre le mail alors le mail il
a été multipliée quasiment par dix en
arrivant à ces dangereuses qui place ses
mais en même temps c'est passionnant
vous avez une synthèse de oui au niveau
de responsabilités maintenant je suis
vois bien que je dois lire beaucoup
d'éléments de synthèse plus que des
romans ou de la littérature le cinéma le
dernier film que vous ayez vu me
demandez pas je garde beaucoup de cinéma
aussi
ja home cinéma c'est chez moi donc hors
jeu avec tous les réseaux etc
mais je vais un peu moins c'est ma basse
que parce que parce qu'au niveau du tay
ninh temps les gens défendu gold je
venais faire du golf me supporter vous
êtes ryder cup mais ces quatre heures
une île goal peut-être plus de succès
est ma dernière question là justement
les d'actualité la chanson de johnny que
vous retenez qui vous aura marqué le
plus
écoutez moi quand j'étais quand j'étais
jeune
je sais que la chanson la plus connue
est le plus entendu c'était
noir c'est noir se faisait il n'y a plus
d'espoir c'est pas très optimiste mais
je me souviens que c'était celle qu'ils
bon après
je voulais déjà un de ses concerts non
mais c'est 1,50 simplement je disais non
pour une idée qui est une vedette reste
un héros national
je regrette que non les harceler
fiscalement comme on l'a receler jusqu'à
ce qu'ils partent de france et c'est
vraiment un type qui aimait la france
qui avait un sentiment d'appartenance à
la france et il était laissé en vie dans
un paradis fiscal c'est ça devient ça
depuis un problème on est un des pays
les plus fiscalisé du monde
faudrait aussi qu'on s'interroge là
dessus et voilà je voulais vous dire ça
vous gêner puisque j'en ai vu des échos
et se marre on ne parle pas beaucoup de
seins
à tout le monde mais bien d'une idée de
la france merci jean michel fourgous
d'avoir participé à ce café politique
[Musique]